it may shape up to be a very crypto
christmas if like me you have yet to do
your holiday shopping crypto could be
the gift that's unique and practical
despite its intense volatility yeah good
news for all the procrastinators out
there and in fact crypto could be a gift
for the hard to please person too
and this is an idea that appears to be
trending more than 60 percent of people
surveyed by the market research platform
cardify say they would love to get
crypto as a gift this holiday season if
not more so than traditional gifts so to
that end we would like to welcome derek
fung he is ceo of cardify derek welcome
back to quick take i know that cardify
collects and aggregates data so what
does the data show about people spending
on cryptocurrency on themselves and for
others
hey sterling great to be back so
we do track a ton of debit and credit
card data with a focus on millennial and
gen z and definitely seeing
a massive trend upwards both on part
data and the server data that we collect
uh we think it's a combination of a
couple things the first one being
crypto's really becoming very mainstream
you know art basel just happened in
miami and the taco town was nfts nfts
nfts i think uh the ease of gifting uh
over the holidays especially with
omniprom variant where consumers don't
really want to travel and and it's
become easier than ever to send a
a gift of crypto whether that's bitcoin
ethereum or any of the other gifts and
definitely in our data we see believe it
or not a lot of consumers are scared of
holding cash because of inflation
everywhere they turn
on the news it's all about inflation is
coming interest rates are coming don't
hold cash and i think it's really the
perfect storm for crypto to be a really
hot topic uh this holiday season crypto
investing is soaring past retail
investing what do you attribute that to
most what's making people so uh bullish
for crypto right now
yeah i think i think a big part of it is
uh a lot a lot easier you know uh in our
in our data seventy percent of consumers
are getting into crypto uh in the past a
lot of that were male consumers but
we're seeing definitely a lot more
female consumers wanting to to get into
crypto and dabbling it for the first
time and i think part of it is also
there's so much talk everywhere every
you know news outlet around inflation
inflation i think today
yeah the us federal reserve will be
making some announcements around
interest rates and so i think there's
just a lot of noise around hey don't
hold cash don't hold cash buy things
that are great in in inflationary
environments and these are things like
potentially crypto
so talk about the different ways of
actually being able to gift crypto to
others this holiday season and what is
available right now uh in the
marketplace
yeah it's a great question so coinbase
actually uh finally finally uh
announced gift cards so gift cards are
probably one of the easiest ways to give
crypto
just go on the coinbase website you can
send someone you know 25 50 worth of
crypto
um but for the true crypto lovers uh
this is you're not really holding crypto
and so probably the easiest way to set
crypto is simply
uh sending you know getting an address
set up getting a wallet set up and
getting all those wallet addresses from
all your friends and loved ones that you
want to send gifts to and just simply
sending
crypto uh through that and through the
wallet so it's a bit more complex but
coinbase has finally rolled up gift
cards for all consumers to use
i love that i think that's the option i
would take it sounds like the easiest
but uh i want to talk about which
coins i guess to give if you're given
the option your all kind data altcoin
data rather show that doge is the most
well-known altcoin but um big crypto
bros like my brother are more obsessed
with solana right now what's the better
gift the one that has more uh household
familiarity or the one that's
potentially gonna actually go to the
moon
it's a great question uh madison so i
think i think it depends i think it's
really what you're betting on and i
think definitely right now it's still
about
if you think inflation and you want to
hedge bitcoin feels like a good choice
if you believe in nfts and that world
and the infrastructure of crypto
ethereum's a great choice
if you believe in in you know solana
potentially being rendered up to
ethereum that's a great choice there's a
coin called axi infinity or you can earn
points for playing games and so if you
believe in that world metaverse that
could be a really great choice and hey
if you love elon musk
then then maybe you buy doge but uh or
sell uh depending on
i mean if you look back in in you know
past charge may be a good time to sell
those by other coins so i think it
really depends but there's definitely a
lot of
noise out there which i think could be a
good or bad thing for consumers but
definitely make sure you meet up on the
coins themselves and for those who are
maybe a little bit more conservative or
risk-averse there are also etfs
exchange-traded funds that allow you to
invest in crypto and i know that the
parent company of cardify uh purpose
excuse me drop has worked with purpose
to come up with a couple of etfs which
are actually based in canada so i'm
curious to find to hear from you first
of all the benefits of investing or
getting a gift in crypto through an etf
versus the actual underlying digital
coin what's the upside the downside to
um getting something adjacent to crypto
versus the actual digital coin itself
yes it's definitely much more seamless
and definitely well much easier for the
new to crypto consumer which is the
consumer of drop and so a lot of these
consumers they don't want to open up a
wallet they they don't want to go
through that hassle and through drop
when we really start through this data
realizing consumers want to hold 60
percent wanting to hold more crypto than
cash or even getting a gift card we said
okay there's something interesting here
but hey let's not make them jump through
all these hoops to sign up for new
accounts because you could lose those
consumers during that process right and
so
part of it two canadian companies come
together purpose being the first etf
globally to actually hold bitcoin versus
tracking it and so it just made it um a
very obvious decision and the ability
for consumer to go in and out in and out
was having without having to deal with
like wallace addresses and the
complexities as a new consumer
made this partnership um uh it made it
make a lot of sense
your data also showed that 235 000
members of gen z millennials like myself
are investing investing in crypto only
through brokerages how does that work
and is that something you could like
gift to someone somehow
yeah i'd say i'd say uh i think it i do
think brokerages it's a lot easier
dabbles for etfs and so now with more
etfs like purpose and in the us more to
come tracking actually holding bitcoin
it's very easy there's still fees that
you have to pay
i'd say the the easiest way to get
through that would be there's actually
fractional share companies there's one
out there called stockpile or you can
actually send someone 25 of a stock or
25 worth of etf so i'd say that would
probably be the easiest way to gift uh
crypto exposure through an actual etf
and not that anyone wants to think about
this when they're giving a gift or when
they're getting a gift but if you do end
up gifting crypto to someone i give
maddie some crypto um when she cashes
out
uh does she
have to pay all the capital gains
i mean do you have to give the gift with
a caveat
yeah it's a great question i think it's
still
in the works you know for sure if it's
an etf and done through the traditional
brokerages those are all taxed and the
government will track all of that
there's new tax
reform coming for actually holding
crypto i would advise
uh those
intrigued to definitely do your research
because it's coming but i'd say it's not
as heavily taxed or you know the process
is still much earlier than if you were
to actually buy an etf so maybe even
better
to get a gift through a traditional
platform like a coinbase
uh really quickly here i know that you
also talked about just how it's super
likely that crypto is going to be a
topic uh this holiday season what advice
do you have for folks approaching family
members who are big fiat lovers to kind
of sell them on crypto
yeah it's a great question i'd say
definitely do their do your research i
think crypto is still a very early asset
class it's gone through a lot of bubbles
uh there's been a lot of talk about an
another bubble coming but ultimately if
you believe
you have to believe in the technology
ultimately if you're
receiving crypto gifting crypto it's
really technology versus all these coins
themselves and so and i think you have
to do it as a long-term fault most
uh investment advisors view you know
five percent exposure maybe to crypto
and just hold it long-term and just
pretend like hey if it goes to zero you
should be okay with it so i think it's
that type of asset class definitely your
research but i think it's a great time
to gift given the the recent market dip
in uh in bitcoin and the vast majority
of currencies in the crypto web
it'll definitely lead to some
interesting conversations around the
dinner table during the holiday season
thank you so much really great practical
gift giving advice when it comes to
crypto derek fung ceo of cardify live in
los angeles